[Music]
and
a
[Music]
you've been
listening let's talk about our democracy
for a minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating more on ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michael hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them it's a dark Brandon economy out
there that's right that's you know I'm
not going to tell the White House what
to do um but I'm going to tell them what
the [__] to
do that's exactly what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna tell them what the [__] to do uh
we need to stop calling a
bomic listen to me very carefully we
need to stop calling it biomics and
start calling it The Dark Brandon
economy it's
right we need to
Rebrand biomics to be the dark Brandon
economy sounds much better
anyways bomic that sounds like wonky and
[__] you know what I mean like who wants
to [__] sit around and listen to a
bunch of people talk about economics is
that what you
want that ain't what the [__] I want I
don't want to do that [__] everyone
knows what dark Brandon means we stole
it away from them they thought it was
really cute you know in the let's go
Brandon the [__] Joe Biden yeah [__] Joe
Biden right all the way into the dark
Brandon economy [__] how about that how
about about them [__] apples huh MAA
you like that you [__]
Nazis CU that's that's really that's
really you know the overall aring story
here is that Democrats do economy better
right don't say economics say economy I
know it sounds kind of stupid right when
you're saying it you're like Tony you
sound like a [__] idiot who cares
stop caring about what what how
something sounds or if it's right stop
doing that what we need to do is win
it's what we need to do and the economy
is winning now it's not great for
everyone
right again I it's not it's not great
for everyone and it's never going to be
every economy isn't great for every
single person it's kind of like trying
to figure out how to get every single
bill that passes and every single
legislative body in this country to
please every single person it's not
going to happen 100% of the time what
are you [__] nuts and in this
attitude of 100% 100% or nothing you
know what I mean well 100% of nothing is
still [__] nothing so get with it
pluck your head out of your ass and
understand that this is the dark Brandon
economy not bomic and I I know they've
been trying to Brand It That Way um and
they've had trouble with
it I it's listen stop saying economics
it sounds like someone's gonna [__]
give throw you a textbook and [__] you
know what I mean that's why I don't do
that [__] on this show pile you up with
a bunch of datas and polls number one
the polls are [__] and most of the time
the data and statistics will put you the
[__] to sleep and how the hell am I
going to keep your attention for two
goddamn hours if I put you asleep with
[__] statistics and
data good
Lord we got a show to run here two hours
a day we got a we got a [__]
democracy to save we got messaging and
narrative to pile
on so this is
important and again I I know I know I
know that a lot of people are gonna push
back on me a little bit here but listen
I'm telling you I'm gonna say dark brand
in economy I I tweeted it earlier I'm
saying it now we're going to Brand it
and you guys are going to go out and do
the world and start tweeting it and say
no it's not the bomic it's dark brand
and
economy and start what you need to start
doing is grab dark Brandon memes maybe
we can make some maybe we can make some
dark Brandon memes that say dark Brandon
economy Howell you can grab the
thumbnail from the show um if you want
to if you want to grab it here let me
show you here here's the um here's the
thumbnail from the show dark Brandon
economy um so grab it if you want to
grab that grab that thing if you want to
grab it dark Brandon economy now I know
it sounds crazy you're like T Tony you
can't just do that [__] I can't [__] I
won't you do anything you want when
you're when you got a microphone and
there's no one telling you what the hell
to do especially when you the audience
are the ones who power this microphone
against Fascism and that's really what
we're talking about here breaking up
fascism if you want if you want Joe
Biden to have a damn good message into
into the fall of 2024 this is it the
dark Brandon economy is it it's the
economy stupid do you remember that so
so a lot of people like Tony by nomics
that's way better because it's already a
hashtag okay [__] your hashtag [__] your
hashtag stick it in your ass [__] all
your memes that you've already made that
are total [__] okay [__] them [__] them
dark Brandon economy is much better way
better and it's getting better the
economy itself Fox News is even
admitting
it Fox News is like ah [__] dark Brandon
kicks ass oh man dark Brandon kicks ass
is this economy stuff [__] we was hoping
he'd have a horrible economy son of a
[__] they love it they love it um
someone's saying [__] you back on the um
on Discord yeah [__] you too
I listen I I I I know I know a lot of
people think [__] her [__] them you know
what I mean a lot of a lot of people
think that I like are I'm gonna like say
something or not say something
because a couple people believe in a
certain thing I don't give a [__] that's
not why you're here you're not here for
me to agree with if you want to go
somewhere where people agree with you go
over to [__] threads okay go to
threads [__] go to go somewhere where
people will agree with you I guess if
you want to live in a [__] bubble if
that's what you want to do that would be
awesome but if you want to live out here
in the
world where people you
know want to [__] compromise want to
make a better life want to make that
this country where it has more equity
and equality for all
people we want to focus in on Liberty
and do the best we can and elect the
people who do policy the best in this
country which in all reality
historically speaking Democrats
economies are way [__] better and I
didn't say Democrats economics de de
Democratic economics are way listen this
is Tony Michaels with the Tony Michaels
podcast and today we're going to talk
about how the Democratic party is much
better historically at economics and
pushing the economy and the GDP higher
um today Joe Biden it is announced that
in the fourth quarter you see what I
mean that's [__] boring that's that's
[__] you're GNA fall
asleep and I was saying it fast good
morning this is Tony
Michaels with the Tony Michaels
podcast sit my coffee today we're going
to talk about how the Democratic party
does economics better for the American
economy it's [__] boring now [__]
over it
exactly people are [__] already
snoring and I'm [__] mocking this
[__] so yes Democrats are better at
economy they're hell of a lot better at
economy they're just better they got
better economies every single [__]
time and it's not it's not it's not like
a thing that people don't know I mean if
you go back to Bill Clinton when he came
in the [__] economy kind of sucked
you know and by the time he was done
after eight years we had a surplus a
budget surplus which has never [__]
happened George W bush crashes the
economy in 2008 Barack Obama gets
elected Barack Obama pulls us out of the
Great Recession which was a Great
Depression if you were around then if
you were around you know it's funny that
about the Great Recession and under
Barack Obama's economy for for eight
years it's the thing is is that the
Millennials were the ones who came of
age like we were just becoming adults um
when 2008 you know when that started and
a lot of people are like oh you
Millennials you don't know [__] about
[__] get the [__] out of here man number
one we're in we're damn near all in our
40s we got children we got Co children
in college that we're paying for we got
401ks we got mortgages that we pay
for and we went through the Great
Recession so get the [__] out of here
okay and and and we were all live during
911 and watch that [__] and we had to
[__] deal with Grant Paul [__]
Hitler so yeah okay spare me the
Millennials never did
anything spare me but Barack Obama had a
great economy right great
economy the the Obama the Barry Obama
economy was
good and then and then [__] Grandpa
Hitler comes in and [__] up the entire
pandemic just botches the entire thing
because he won't listen worth the
[__] damn damn near tanks us the only
thing that the only thing that made sure
that we hung on was Democrats in the
Senate and the house to make sure they
gave covid relief to
Americans and then when when dark
Brandon got elected he started his
economy with huge covid relief package
to make sure Americans got back on their
[__]
feet and it worked it worked and we
would have worked more if we would have
actually elected people who would have
negotiated the child tax credit to
continue you know that little monthly
check that came in the mail cames
directly into your bank account because
you know you're raising a you're raising
a bunch of young
ones yeah that's [__] money pumped
into the economy that's what that is and
what we should do is tax the [__]
rich now if you want if you want to
compare the dark Brandon economy to the
grandpa Hitler economy what he wants to
do
is not tax rich people at
all oh yeah and he's not going to he's
not going to do anything to stem
inflation he'll drop interest rates so
rich people can borrow money for nothing
when they pay no taxes because that's
the reality of
it so what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do you gonna vote for dark Brandon
the dark Brandon
economy or GL Grandpa Hitler fascism huh
which is it what do you want you want
democracy or you want autocracy these
are the
things and these are the words that we
should be using bomic is not a word it's
not a word it's kind of a fancy [__]
ridiculous combination of words it's a
wrong combination
words it's wrong it's [__] wrong dark
Brandon's so much better and I know I'm
going on and on and on and on and on
about rebranding this but this is how
you Rebrand
stuff it's how you make a sell cuz I
know there's still a lot of you out
there in the comments section like
[__] [__] this [__] we've been
working on bomic for six goddamn months
I've tweeted a thousand tweets with that
goddamn hashtag do you know how many
memes I've made I don't give a [__] but
stick those in the trash it's okay you
can start over it's not that big of a
[__] deal it really
isn't um Tanya says keep going on and on
and on and on Tanya you got a good point
listen that that's how [__] sticks
that's how messaging Cascades that's why
I'm so effective at it and I hate to Pat
myself on the back but I really am
effective at
this I have a certain talent for talking
into microphone I have a certain talent
for capturing people's attention for two
two straight hours I could probably do
it for three hours if um if I had the
ability as far
as takes money um you know we got to get
some sponsors and stuff other than the
fake ones we have you know like la Juice
1000 and the super gri gummies we're
working on it though I promise we're
working on getting some actual sponsors
um that will that will give us the
ability to do a lot more stuff here at
the Tony Michaels podcast and also just
yell and scream into the microphone
Until We Can't
Stop just keep going just keep trucking
and keep pounding them and yes we are
gonna mock the [__] out of them oh my
God are we going to mock the [__] out of
these fools I got I got some mockery for
m r today Mitt Romney saying the right
[__] into the microphone but I'm going
to mock him you know why I'm going to
mock him because he remains a
republican that's right until Mitt
Romney just gets out in front of a
microphone and publicly switches his
party affiliation I'm going to mock him
I'm going to make fun of him I'm going
to attack him it is going to happen I'm
not going to stop that
[__] it's not going to stop I'm not g to
stop you're not going to stop we're not
going to stop we got to save our [__]
democracy we got to save our
constitutional republic here it is a
thing we have to
do and again I said yesterday I'm
willing to say just about [__]
anything I
think even if I've even if I've got to
go against the
establishment to kill the hashtag Biden
nomics and Rebrand it dark Brandon
economy listen I'm telling you when when
when [__] mouth breathers out there
hear dark Brandon economy there what
it's not
bics it's dark Brandon they created dark
Brandon they created dark
Brandon and then we [__] snatched it
away from him and then the best part
about it is is the economy part how the
Imagine see that's that's the thing that
um a lot of messagers don't really think
about like they don't really think what
are they going to say when we say this
[__] like when we say something or they
what are they going to say
back you're opposition is what I'm
talking I'm not talking about the people
who are going to retweet you and spread
the hashtag and all that [__] right
they'll [__] agree listen if the
white house today said that Tony
Michaels is on to something man godamn
that dark Brandon economy that's a hell
of a lot better than
bomic that's [__] a hell of a lot
better we're just going to [__] scrap
all that [__] and just do what he says
that's what they should do but if they
did that if they did
that they would be much better off but
most of the time they don't think ahead
I I I'll go back let's rewind a little
bit in the dark Brandon
economy right and dark Brandon's
Reign that's the other thing we should
lean into is the whole thing where they
think Joe Biden's a dictator we should
lean into it and just call it dark
Brandon you goddamn right he's a
dictator Ator we want dark Brandon as a
dictator just lean into it [__] them
[__] them that I mean they're sit
standing in line talking about how
[__] how how how [__] Trump is
their goddamn Messiah sent by God and
you think it's gonna sound dumber than
that okay you think anything we say is
gonna sound dumber than what dictator
Scorch you're not you're not g to sound
dumber than they are you're not it's
okay and it's okay to sound a little
dumb it really is I know you don't think
it is you're like no Tony we need to
sound smart like we use periods and [__]
we need to use the proper punctuation
get the [__] out of here with your with
your spell
check listen I'm telling you this
messaging and narrative if it's sloppy
who gives a good goddamn it doesn't
matter it doesn't need to be anything
but sloppy if you want to know the
honest truth that's that's some of the
best goddamn [__] that comes out of that
comes out of messaging I mean some of
the best stuff we've come up on this
show has just been us [__] flinging
[__] on the wall right just flinging
[__] on the wall and I know I'm going on
and on and on about this dark brand in
economy and the messaging but I'm
telling
you if you get with me on this and just
try it out just give it a run just give
it a go the next week or
two and everyone kind of like hey this
is a better word this is a better phrase
but I want to rewind let's go back to
that let's rewind back to bad messaging
right because they don't really think
about this
[__] remember build back better holy
[__] that is horrible is [__]
horrible they wanted the BBB thing so
they could call it the
BBB you know what I mean BBB Debbie said
ugly ass hat is that because it's red
look I'm trying to make Red Hats great
again you know what are wear able I'm
trying to make Red Hats wearable again
all right Jesus Christ appreciate the
appreciate the comment on the hat that's
why I wear them to piss you off so
you'll comment engage that's all you got
to do but build back better that's the
reason why they wanted BBB because it
was easy to engage it was easy to say
because it's a it's an acronym
BBB so they it come up with build back
better right that [__] I mean think
about when someone hears build back
better they're like wait a second you
mean I got to build some
[__] you mean like I'm going to pick up
a [__] hammer and put on a goddamn
tool belt what the hell is this I
thought you politicians were gonna do
this thing not us we we got to do this
for
you what the hell I mean it would have
been so much better if they would have
build it as an education bill cuz there
was a lot of Education funding built
into the bill back better the BBB Russia
mar mar mar if they would have just
build it as an as an education bill I
mean if they wanted to go with BBB they
could have went with the big bird bill
right Big Bird Bill oh Big Bird Sesame
Street ABCs one 123s education bingo
bango bongo got it right boom it was an
education Bill all of a sudden from
infrastructure bill which sounds really
a heavy lift especially when they were
trying to do two two at the same time
you remember that they were trying to do
two infrastructure bills they were
trying to do the infrastructure Bill and
then the human infrastructure Bill to
build back better
bill it's just nonsense and they were
trying to make them two infrastructure
bills when they could have just said hey
we're going to get infrastructure and
education the American people went yeah
it sounds [__] good let's do
that let's do that no they gave the
Republicans the inroad because they
didn't think about what the hell their
opposition was going to say about this
[__] and how they were going to build
this [__] before they said what they
said they're like no this sounds good
people will people will like this well
what about the people that'll hate it
well they'll I mean
um I don't know I don't know they
they'll probably build a message against
it so strong that we won't be able to
pass it but let's do it
anyways
it's like biomics again it sounds like a
[__] College course who wants to
[__] talk about
economics I mean everyone will talk
about the economy godamn did you see
what gas went down to it's a good
economy [__] son of a [__] gas dropped
below $3 now it's damn near barreling in
on
250 godamn this is a good economy so
much better economy than it was last
year they don't say economics normal
average [__] don't take
economics classes and don't want
to okay most people who even have a 401k
don't even know how the [__] stock
market Works they have no clue how
mutual funds work they get big books
every year because they gotta [__]
send them the books and the disclosures
and [__] for their for their [__]
mutual
funds in their IRAs or their 401ks or
whatever the [__] they got right and
they open and they're like godamn this
is like [__] trying to read a foreign
language yeah because it
is it
is because they got a lot of [__]
they're doing you know what I mean like
the average American Worker Works 40
hours a week 50 60 80 hours a [__]
week because they got two [__] jobs
right and it's getting better under the
dark Brandon economy it really
is the GDP is going up but what we have
to do Under the dark Brandon economy is
we have to reelect people who are
willing to [__]
tax tax the rich so us normal average
folks can make sure to set policy in
place that we get our portion of the GDP
rather in the dark branded economy that
it be higher wages and negotiating those
higher wages which hey under the dark
brand economy labor union has never been
stronger never been stronger because
under the dark brand and economy the
president of United States back the
unions back the American worker do you
see how this language Works do you see
how the messaging works instead of some
wonky dumb [__] talking about statistics
and data it's the same thing it's the
same [__] you just leave all that
garbage and trash out that no one wants
to
hear this is how it works folks this is
how messaging
works this is how you actually set a
[__] narrative in this
country and I know it feels like well
Tony's just he's just bragging about how
he can cut that's what I
do it's what I do I don't I don't just
go watch
MSNBC and just repeat it have you ever
seen me do that go watch some [__]
newscast or read someone else's [__]
tweets and just regurgitate whatever the
[__] you can go read in the first place
do you ever see me go get a court motion
and yeah here let me let me pull up this
court motion and we'll break down line
by line while you shouldn't give a
[__] do you ever see me do no because
does that matter no it didn't [__]
matter those aren't kitchen table
issues they're not like this border [__]
I'm going to talk about it again today
acting like people crossing an imaginary
line is kitchen table issues no one
gives a [__] at their kitchen table
about someone coming in this country to
make a better life for themselves are
you [__] [__] me you think people
are sitting around just other than the
cultist are the people who [__] sit
and watch The Boob Tube all day
listening to oh there's a problem at the
borders problem at the borders problem
at the borders problem it's Crisis
crisis Crisis crisis it's not a [__]
crisis the crisis we got is in
Washington
DC we do not have two parties in this
country that believe in democracy that
do not believe in the American dream
that do not believe in the American
Experience anymore there's only one of
them that the majority of those people
of that party [__] believe in that
[__] anymore believe in [__]
Liberty believe that our country was
built on the backs of migrants built on
the backs of
slaves knows that to be the [__]
truth that's what we need to get back to
we need to stop stop [__] acting like
we need to be [__] smart and say it
smart like we need to sound smart when
we talk get the [__] out of here man you
think most average Americans have time
to sit around and [__] worry about
how elitist you want to sound get the
[__] out of here with this
[__] they're sitting around the K
kitchen table worrying about how much
[__] gas prices are that's why they
were blaming Joe Biden when gas prices
were high because they couldn't find
anyone else to [__] blame
when in reality in years past and
decades past they blame the [__]
corporations in the goddamn oil
companies not no [__]
president I mean no one's given dark
Brandon credit this morning about how
[__] the gas is getting down to 250 a
gallon the media is not like whoa Joe
Biden's the best president of all time
[__] gas prices are damn near down to
250 they're not doing that [__] and they
won't do that [__] because the president
doesn't have much to do with the actual
price at the pump now he can [__] try
to Institute policies in his
administration to affect the dark
Brandon economy which is going [__]
well and
swimmingly and you see how it's much
easier to brag about the economy when
you call it the dark Brandon economy do
you see
that and yeah it's a long ways to go but
it's never going to suit everyone 100%
100% of people 100% of the time the
economy is not going to but if we get
down to these kitchen table
issues and we show the world what the
[__] the right wants to do with these
kitchen table issues like what do they
want to do with gas prices well they
want to check your kids
genitalia in elementary schools do what
yeah that's what they want to do about
gas and they don't want to do anything
about gas price what do they want to do
about making sure that migrants are are
AEM ated into our country and we welcome
them and make them part of our economy
oh well see what what they want to do is
they want to deport all brown people and
probably black people too and really
anyone who likes them as well do what no
that's not that's the opposite yeah they
don't really want to do
anything what what about what about a
medical bill what if I get a medical
bill in the mailbox that will make me go
broke like a $50,000 medical bill what
what what what is the right one to do
about that well see they really they
believe hard that Trump is a God and
he's their Savior and they think he's
going to repeal Americans access to
health care so you're probably going to
get more of those medical bills that are
going to make you go broke if you want
to know the honest
truth what so so what do you mean
they're not going to do anything about
it well no actually they're going to do
the
opposite all right well what about what
about education like what what about
that like that's a that's a real
important issue in most communities
we got schools sometimes are the biggest
employers or some of the biggest you
know Community hubs U children are fed
there every day so it's a way to you
know fend off childhood hunger I mean
there's all we can educate our [__]
people so they can be part of the
economy what about that what does the
right want to do about that well they
really don't want you to have public
school or public education they want to
take that entitlement that we've had for
you know over well over 100 years
away they want to destroy that
infrastructure and matter of
fact so wait so they want to do nothing
no well actually the opposite they want
to not do something for you they want to
take it away from you and make your
situation worse at your kitchen table
these are kitchen table issues and this
is how you talk about it this is how you
message it Democrats have always been
[__] horrible at this always have
been horrible at this and I'm telling
you right now right here as I sit as I
do two hours every single week day
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific what I'm telling you
right now this morning is that the dark
Randon economy is alive and well and
it's going to get better and better and
if we make sure to do our part and get
rid of [__] fascist out of our
goddamn government then people who are
serious about policy who are serious
about doing something for the American
people at their kitchen table about
those issues that they care so much
about if we do the work that democracies
do and we use our ballot to send a
message to the the do nothing Nazis
because that's what they are they're
[__] do nothing Nazis they do nothing
matter of fact they do the opposite they
take [__] away from
America
country so let's do our job and let's do
democracy and let's do this show godamn
we got Cliffs we got Cliffs we got Cliff
we got Cliff bottom of the hour he's
coming on I'm real soon don't worry he's
going to be on real soon don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right back
right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker Convoy
boy there's Tammy by the time we reached
DC we was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way we
got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again your's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more more of
them Doritos you like the red bag not
the live loving blue one in your absence
I discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I a even seen my
cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] them [__] them [__]
[__] them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the
show it's Thursday it's bottom of the
hour you know what time it is we have a
special guest think coming on on
Thursday some other days too when we
have some special [__] going
on but we've got him here clip Shor is
here just as I promised but first first
I want to um go through something that
we've been talking about the last few
days it's called operation go commando
that's right operation go commando you
talk about messaging and
narrative my pal I me I'm gonna start
calling him my pal James Carville my my
cinjun brother from another mother
decides that he's gonna lean into
mockery and he don't give a [__] about
it and I like it and he's gonna start
the Carville Commandos so what we're
going to do is we're going to court a
coalition we're going to see if the
Carville Commandos and the rat [__]
Patrol want to join the [__] them fam in
a coalition to defend democracy and use
mockery to do it so we're we're in full
force with operation go Commandos so
make sure uh as you're out there you're
and you're finding these coalitions
these groups of people who are already
gathered up and ready to fight for
democracy and save their democracy and
their pro-democracy it doesn't matter if
we disagree on a few issues that it
doesn't matter who gives a [__] we are
going to go full Commando on these some
[__] and we're going to go operation
go commando on these some [__] so
make sure you're out there make sure
you're tagging Carville make sure you're
getting my attention if you find these
coalitions it is very very very
important that we push it and also very
important is to introduce my guest you
know him he's back again as he is every
week Cliff sheor Cliff how are you my
friend I'm doing well man how are you
doing I'm doing [__] fantastic I'm
doing [__] fantastic and the reason
why is because everything's working out
just like I thought it would I mean
pretty
much with the with the New Hampshire
primer it's a very Dr Evil like
statement yes it is well you know I I I
um I don't always like to be correct
because sometimes when I'm correct I'm
like that really sucks you know um but
but we we we are seeing stuff play out
the way that I thought we would see it
play out um with the New Hampshire
primary thing tery where you don't come
in with sort of a uh a pre sort of
formed bias about everything based upon
how it will help you move up in your
career at the New York Times or CNN I
have that too and so the weird thing is
if you have a functioning cerebral
cortex some know it as the brain and you
do not have the the issue of I must be
completely full of [__] to make my dumb
corporate Overlord happy yeah NE us have
that
problem I definitely don't have that
problem I certainly don't either trust
me so it's it's pretty easy then to look
at what we would call all available
evidence and come to conclusions like
Nikki Haley's going to get her ass
kicked you know or and I think you and I
discussed this she even came closer in
New Hampshire than I thought I thought
she was she'd do well I thought she
might come within 10 12 points I think I
said a dozen you know yeah I I thought
it would be between 15 and 20 is where I
thought she was going to land but it
doesn't matter in the end we both sort
of knew she'd do well there and that's
because they're I mean the Republicans
are all saying this of course they're
saying this as they cry we're saying
this as we laugh but it's because most
of the people voted for we're basically
either never Trump you know this part's
[__] nuts uh I still kind of call
myself a republican but only you know
part of the time Republicans or they're
Independents probably a few Democrats
because you know not that many because
clearly Biden even though it wasn't an
official primary cleaned up well done
Dean Phillips maybe you should go back
to the family booze business who who is
it h some dude who like I think we had
we talked about a lot of money in booze
and I you know if my family which by the
way my family two generations ago was
actually in the booze business um they
clearly weren't what kind of what kind
of booze what kind of booze they had a
liquor store in New York I don't know I
should find out more details but I wish
they'd been as good at it as his family
because I from what I can tell he's
worth 75 million I'm not not worth that
um so the point is what the [__] is he
doing like I I I I swear to God I don't
understand these people I never
understand these kinds of people he had
a perfectly like perfect setup career in
the Democratic party could have been in
leadership in the house blah blah blah
instead he would have gone he would have
gone unnoticed for decades he's so he's
so unnoticeable like he is but that it
doesn't always work that way if you've
got money you've got influence and he L
[__] money and in the house he could
have given lots of money and bought lots
of votes for leadership elections well
Cliff I I believe that's where um you
know maybe we're not having the correct
conversation is that um if he's worth so
much money and he gathered up so much
Haron Hitler money I don't know if you
know that um but I think I believe I
know har what douche har hey I'm gonna
hang out with my black friend Clarence
Thomas today is that the we're talking
about Carlin Hitler yeah the one who has
the signed copy of minec he loves Hitler
he [__] loves it he's got a statue
who Among Us doesn't have a copy of
minec and some old Hitler artifacts by
our bed that's signed and sign and you
bring it out and brag to people you're
like look I got a Hitler signed copy of
mine
comp The Arc of the Covenant from right
below them and now that's right beside
my bed right now I I can go on and on
think about Nazis just I come up with so
many great you know all these great
movies from the 70s 80s and whatever
they actually mocked Nazis instead of
wanting to be Nazis that was the point I
was gonna make it was all these people
that that you know were were either
Boomers or were the silent Generation
generation before and had to fight in
that [__] War right and hated Nazis
with a [__] passion and hated the
fact that our CIA let some of them some
of the top intelligence guys from the
Nazis in here and worked with them watch
all those great movies like Marathon Man
and you know uh three days of the Condor
those great [__] 70s and basically
all these movies are about Nazis [__]
suck we hate them and that went into the
80s of course with Indiana Jones and
other stuff uh instead of the current
Republican party who's like Nazis hey
hey that's not a bad ideology we can
force people to do what we want them to
do if we if we become fascist naism that
sounds very fascinating I want to shut
that out so but but um back to the dean
Phils just for a second just for a
second I believe the reason why Dean
Phillips exist in the first place is
because um there's Republican money
sperm got somewhere and found the wrong
EG well that is true yeah that well I
mean the science behind it but um I'm
talking about Steve Schmidt um and I'm
not afraid to attack Steve because I
don't give a [__] [__] him um honestly
I'm very scared to attack him so I'm not
gonna say that guy I know I know I know
some people are like well he did he was
on MSNBC and and he's friends with
Nicole Wallace and and Rachel I don't
give a [__] [__] Steve Schmidt the
reason why the de Phillips exist in the
first place is because Steve Schmidt
needed a goddamn
payday honestly look you know I I there
are some there are folks who are uh who
one who was a former Lincoln project who
is a good friend of mine I think he's a
great guy and I would defend to the end
that he was an honest guy and you know
whatever there's some other Lincoln
project guys I don't know that well I'm
okay with Steve Schmidt I don't I never
worked in a race where I got to know him
I never any of that stuff he always
obviously was a self-promoting buffoon
and but I was willing to overlook that
as I'm willing to overlook lots of stuff
with people you and I disagree on this
sometimes when they're fighting for the
right cause but how many times does this
guy have to be like hey look there's
Starbucks money I'll go [__] that
election up and hand it to you know mean
like after that I there was no coming
back as far as I was concerned but
everybody let him back and oh you know
he just needed a little Starbucks money
and then he he does this I mean the the
thing I put up this this this um this
tweet of his that went viral mind did of
his where nine days before he accepted
the offer from Dean Phillips he had
tweeted out this you know one of Biden
sitting in the Resolute you know at the
Resolute desk making a speech and saying
we're so lucky to have this man behind
the resol right now and and you know
went into all the stuff he always goes
into where he goes into the Americana
and the you know since the Revolution
and since the Battle of one of his
stupid [__] diet tribes right you
know since Fort
tyoga blah blah blah you know he starts
getting all like te eyed and [__] and
like nine days L that's all fake by the
way and if you don't know it's fake
because of what you're about to say go
ahead well I was saying and then nine
days later he's like wait how many zeros
are there on that chat right it's
amazing it's amazing how money will
change a [__] it is it's amazing
it's amazing how to change all have to
make and I respect the [__] out of you
and I'm not just saying that because I'm
on your show because you make almost no
compromises that I can tell we all have
to make some here and there uh I mean to
get through life in general um you know
try try having a family and you know
you'll know there's plenty of
compromises there yeah when the kids and
my wife don't want to watch the [__]
you know the James Bond movie I gotta
deal with it I mean like there's there's
compromises to to be made but but and
even in this career look there are times
where where when something that I don't
think is something that is that
important I have to weigh certain things
they're easy things right easy things
like the things that Steve Schmidt gets
wrong those are easy don't take team
Phillips money because Joe Biden is the
one who's going to keep us in democracy
there's some you know I try to not be
judgmental fully of people because I get
it I've had to at times like not say
certain things that were on my mind
because of the fact that democracy is
still my guiding principle and in the
end I want that most of all but I will
say like you know there's level where
you can make a few compromises there's
you know and it keep there's there's
just a point you can get to where it's
like you're one big [__] he's the
Great Compromise is what he [__] is
also it works in both ways because he's
the Great Compromise for money he's also
probably you know trying to elect
somebody that'll bring back slavery so
he's the Great Compromise right well and
and and that's I I think the point is
that is um ultimately you have to take
some commentators and some strategists
and some analyst um whatever the hell
they want to call themselves um you got
to take them with the grain I refer to
myself as douchebag but everybody has
their own for what they do I mean you
know Steve like you said was a good
warrior for democracy until he wasn't
till he was like oh how much democracy
democracy yeah [__] democracy I'll just
go well and and ultimately Steve knew
that Dean Phillips would fail like he
knew
it he knew so he might as well take the
the money and just you know be a slug
but here's the thing the dude is busy
making the Republican arguments right
now he you know he's he's attacking
Biden on his age and this he tweeted out
that unbeliev I don't think that'll
really hurt anybody because it's so dumb
if you saw where he tweeted out that map
that they always love to tweet out that
shows how much more land is Republican
than Democratic because mountains and
canyons and [__] Farmland votes as
you know it's not actually you know all
this huge red with just the blue dots
it's like
good to know the Grand Canyon [__]
votes I'm really that sucks you know and
and he tweeted out I mean he's just he's
be he's becoming what happens is is you
may start off with a I'm just gonna you
know do a little run here I'm not going
to criticize Biden build some name
recognition I'll drop out early but then
you get your ego grows or people start
whispering in your ear you get a little
worse a little worse you know at this
point we have we have to worry the
[__] and I do something with no
labels and I I don't know so who who
knows Oh you mean you mean Dean
Phillips yeah you think wait wait wait
wait wait wait I I want to smoke this
out real quick before I show you a piece
a clip here I've got a piece of news it
shows Maga perfectly um after they have
done what they've done over the last few
primaries but so what you're saying is
is you think that Dean Phelps could
possibly be on the No Labels ticket is
that what you're saying I'm not I mean
certainly they'd love him to be I don't
well I shouldn't say that he doesn't
have any name recognition I don't know
that he's the person they want on the
ticket but somebody they want I think
they want Joe mansion that's what I
think they want too so or C in cinema
and if somebody like that with more Nam
they don't want Christians they're not
gonna get Republicans crazy so they may
not want her she's right but here's the
thing whether it's show man whatever who
maybe they'll [__] pull Joe liberman
is he still he probably who they could
open up his they could go find his Crypt
and pull him out of there if anyone
doesn't know Joe liberman took away the
possibility of us having a a public
option
the the one and
onlyis what I like to do is not be like
the the MRE media so I try to break [__]
down and I know you do that too there
are people that are no longer alive
because if Joe liberman was pissed off
at the Democratic party right and his
wife was on a board of big farmer one of
the companies and he and he well he
lives in the state where all the health
insurance companies reside exactly he
lived in Connecticut there's just in
case you thought Joe mansion and Kirsten
Cinema were New Creations before them it
was Ben Nelson before him it was there's
always one [__] usually a couple of
them undermining the rest of the party
uh if we can't get ourselves up to 55
undering the American people well yes I
mean I think I think that's I think
that's more no you're right I don't care
about the if the Democratic party
weren't the only party trying to help
people I just was saying that because by
extension what Democrats were trying to
do and generally are trying to do from
my perspective is helpful well Barack
Obama was trying to do the heaviest lift
uh in a hundred years and got it
accomplished I think um oh incredible I
mean again what was done overall they
didn't they just they [__] up on the
marketing they didn't sell the most
important parts right well they sold it
as the ACA and really honestly um like
this morning I was saying they should
have leaned into Obamacare from the very
beginning because once Democrats really
leaned into Obamacare it sold like crazy
because people like well he's smart he
did a good job so yeah Obamacare greatan
into you know like any message that you
try to sell you should have two or three
key lines key talking points key
components they should have been right
away it should have been you know can't
be kicked off insurance for life no
pre-existing conditions your kids can
stay on till their 25 done those are the
three most important like the most
popular as I remember and it shouldn't
they should table issues kitchen table
issues right they shouldn't even been
talking about the whole thing it's those
three things they should have been
repeating add [__] nauseum but right
we could have a a four hour before we
before we get to the the tape here
because I I got a tape Jesus Christ what
is this the 90s um I got a clip here go
the tape let's go to the tape let's go
to the tape live sorry put the put the
VHS in put the VHS in and Rewind it to
this time stamp no I have datamax dude
I'm holding out I'm not [__] giving
up I'm not doing BHS I'm not doing it um
so here's the thing is this morning uh I
watched Fox News and I'll show that clip
too or that tape I'll show the tape of
Fox News bragging about the dark brand
in economy now the Democrats and the
administration have done themselves no
Duty by calling it B nomics it's a
horrible hashtag it's a horrible word
because it because it sounds like a
goddamn College course that you got to
take um no it does so this morning I
rebranded I I thought you made a good
point there we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna Rebrand venomics I'm gonna
Force the administration to do this I
don't give a [__] I'm gonna Force
everyone online to do this I don't give
a [__] we're g to call it the dark brand
in economy because the dark brand in
economy is a hell of a lot better I like
now you're a badass and you're you know
you got the glowing eyes exactly it's a
badass economy and it's an economy not
econ it's not a college course you know
what I mean and you know what else again
Tony it should be very simple right pick
and it's hard because there's so many
good aspects of it pick three or four
things lowest unemployment in [__] 50
years be well beyond full employment
right the inflation level has dropped I
don't even know what the percent is but
it's like [__] you know through the
floor do that because that also defends
you against their [__] inflation
charges right come out the third one you
know where wages have gone up and you
know in EN amount show that
infrastructure project you want me to
give you the three that I would go with
here's unemployment number off hand the
other ones I don't know off hand so the
three I would go with right now in this
moment and and you can always you know
work around and change them a bit but
the one I'd go with moment gasoline is
dropping to 250 a gallon yeah I didn't
care unemployment is as low as it's ever
been and the stock market is high as
it's ever been boom those
three perfect Jesus wow a guy that knows
how to message I'm sure they'll never
talk to you again Tony the best part of
that is part two and part three are like
it's poetry one down one up like anybody
who understands how people understand
stuff like you they understand things in
threes and they understand things if
you've got a perfect metaphor to layout
this up this like that's the way people
get stuff dark Brandon economy dark
brand economy gasoline going down to
250 lowest unemployment highest stock
market I'm using that from now on I will
credit you dark brand economy I want you
to steal it I want you to go on every
show and say no more biomics only dark
brand in
economy there's three things and and I
promise everybody watching I'm not just
kissing Tony's ass no um because we do
argue and disagree about not argue in a
nasty way but we disagree about stuff
here and there but that [__] was
messaging wise as somebody who's done
this for a while for a living like that
was [__] brilliant that's I mean
that's that's the only and really
honestly because because the this fall
needs to be at a minimum for Biden right
cuz it's not going to be that hard of a
sale so it needs to be at a minimum if
you're continuing to go on and on and on
and on in datas and facts and statistics
the American people are G like we think
you're full of [__] it sounds like
you're overselling this idea dark brand
in and it sounds like with biomics you
want to [__] you wantan to I gotta go
to a three-week course and take a test
and all this [__] [__] that [__] I don't
want to take no goddamn test I just I
want to live my life I want the economy
good I want gas prices to be good I want
to have a job and I want my 401k to be
high so gas is gas is going down to 250
yeah e the the the unemployment's
tanking unemployment is the lowest it's
ever been and the stock market is high
that stuff's good and you have the
numbers ready if people ask them but you
give you don't need to give them the
numers is you want Trends you want
emotions from people like have you ever
heard a republican give you a number
unless they were trying to scare you
about Democrats it's almost helpful
they're too [__] stupid to out
numbers for but but but you know the the
most effective ads and and videos and
things they've done on abortion rights
are talking to these women who've been
denied and have been harmed by these
[__] you know by the these
Evangelical losers by Mr Mr I'll I'll
look at my son's porn Mike Johnson that
creepy [__] so as far as I'm concerned
like you know what do you think wait
wait a second wait a second this is a
point where we can mock them what do you
think is micro Johnson's the wiener of
the house what do you think his favorite
porn is that his son watches what do you
think it is like when he gets sent to
him he's like whoa I re like what do you
think he like he's like hey we're gonna
have to call off all meetings today I've
got an appointment with a bottle of
lotion like what do you think it is that
that his son sends him that Christian
here's the thing F first of all I I
think it's likely gay
Bo that's his favor like right there
that I mean he's probably he's probably
looking at Old not that there's anything
wrong with it not that there's anything
wrong with of course there isn't it's
only something wrong with it when you
call everybody else wrong for being it
and then you know secretly there's at
least a 78% chance that you are you're
in the speaker's office in the closet
jerking off to to do two dudes raming
each other he's got old pictures of
Peter North up in the closet there you
know he does
otherwise otherwise it's got to be Mia
Khalifa because you know he loves
non-white women because it makes him
feel Superior kind of like when he
adopts kids so it's the same Theory
right like that's what I'm thinking oh
okay all right all right well I'll go
with that I'll go with that I don't
remember where we going I just wanted to
stop and Mock and mock the Speaker of
the House for can't believe we're
actually having a conversation about
which what we're talking about was this
oh messaging that works uses emotion and
it uses easy he doesn't get buried in
statistics it's easy straightforward
talking points for people you had that
on the economy I was pointing out why
they're what you would call more of an
aggressive sort of negative messaging as
Republicans on abortion rights works so
well because they've been getting up
sitting up with women and showing their
stories who've been who have have these
outrageous things happened to them and
and some of whom have have been arrested
maybe have gone to the hospital and bled
and because these [__] who have
done this so the point is is is that
that's where you want to keep it if you
start going into The Well
38.2% of the women in Indiana aren't
able to access then everybody's just
like oh my God I may poke my
right right right can we can we just get
on with the fact that Grandpa Hitler
brags about overturning roie Wade which
is Paving the way for republicans and
States to criminalize pregnancies and
ban their privacy in doctor's offices
you see how that messaging works boom I
already written just talking to you have
the ad written in my head you keep
showing 15 to 20 seconds maybe last 10
seconds of testimony or speeches by
these women as they're crying and
telling you their stories and you keep
putting you flash in between to Trump's
in saying I did it I'm proud of it I
overturned row and you go to another
story and then you go back to Trump
saying that again there needs to be a
punishment for the women and then you go
back to another woman I mean it's easy
it writes itself does it does that's the
price they'll pay for that for having a
diarhea of the mouth dumb [__] as their
as their nominee well you know speaking
of that speaking that that's what this
clip is but before we go to this this
this tape before we go to the tape I
want to point out pazzi says here chicks
with dicks and big titties this is how I
can count on my audience see these your
audience really comes through for you
they're they're liberal Warriors they
love democracy and they love mockery
they love say Mike Johnson is watching
certain scenes from The Hangover Part
Two again and again if you saw that
movie and you know what I'm talking
about maybe you don't
but here here is a here is a here is um
this tape here this is apparently Maga
um after they have picked uh Donald
Trump Grandpa Hitler as as their nominee
this is a this is a very apparently this
is real we'll watch it I don't think
it's what the hell is that
oh all right so I've got my truste
stopwatch and here they come down the
hill looks like in the lead and here
comes
out that was a bad idea at Riverside
Park
Global News there's there's a prime exam
there's there's a rendition of manga
picking in the Republican Party picking
Donald Trump as their nominee because
that's exactly what's GNA happen I I
don't know need more Clips like that
videos I created my channel I
think I put that on the internet I was
like it's great that's great now the
reason why they picked Grandpa Hitler
though the reason why they picked rample
Hitler Cliff as you know they want a
Theocratic monarchy and they really want
a they really want a dictator a a dict
taster listen I want to taste dick just
for one day only one day I want it all
in my mouth all of it I want to taste it
I don't know maybe he's been hanging out
with the micro Johnson too much but I I
want to show you this tape because this
tape feels like to me their wet dream
this feels like what they want America
to be let's let's take a look at
this
[Music]
I'm going to
come you can do the double Trump jack
off hand Dan Noy
rules oh my God so you see all the
people like clapping and cheering and
they're all on the exact same uniform
they're all in the exact same clothes
and it looks like a military now they're
all Miserable as [__] you can tell
because they know if they don't clap and
they don't cheer and they don't act like
they love this person and think he's the
Messiah then they're [__] dead like
they're dead
so difference I can see in that clip and
what Trump wants for us is that Kim
Jong-un has a better haircut do you
think so you think you think he has a
better aircut I mean I think it's a
close race I think it's a close race I
think he Kim Jong gets about a maybe one
and a quarter out of 10 Donald Trump's
at a 0 65 right okay well I mean I'm
estimating here you
know yeah now for people who don't know
this is a volleyball game that the uh
the dictator the murderous [__]
authoritarian in North Korea has now not
only you sit there clapping the whole
time that well I mean you know you
either clap or
die know at some point might just be
worth taking the bullet honestly I mean
I mean I'm sure some of them do on a
regular basis like I just can't take
this anymore but look look at them here
look at them here here here's here's an
image they're standing up cheering um
and and they're all in the same goddamn
clothes same goddamn uniform and so it
looks like you know by the way I I know
this is not the exact topic we're
discussing but related there should be
ads with you know about him with him
praising every single one of these types
of leaders you know there's a I'm in
Cincinnati and it was here it was a
cincinnatian who was kidnapped if you
may remember ended up dying in North
Korean custody in their prison um and I
have to believe his family and all of
them are not really appreciative When
Donald Trump is talking about his
beautiful love letters with Kim Jong Un
I just think we should the if the Biden
campaign were agile on this stuff and
you know super packs independent groups
I mean whenever this guy Praises a
dictator find out the people in this
country who that dictator has hurt
because there's probably been a lot of
them and make sure that they're seeing
that this guy has praised them or just
show tap like that of what his wet dream
is because his wet dream is to make
people clap for him or that he'll kill
them that's his wet dream oh my God he
wants to be a dictator so badly oh yeah
well he does and he knows manga's dumb
here's a clip of him and this I think
this is real it may be AI but I think
it's real let's listen hey did you see
the lasted poll from New Hampshire I
told you maguga was [__] dumb 80% of
my followers totally I mean totally
believe the big lie I really I really
thought the big lie would just [__]
die oh yeah okay
[Music]
so okay is it real or is it AI Tony is
it or is it AI yeah I mean you know I
guess that's a good question here um the
thing is is that in reality what he's
saying is true um but what we made him
say is not real he did not actually say
that I mean he should say that but he
didn't actually it's the truth from
numer numerous published reports he does
say that in private right I mean he does
I don't know if he says it exactly I'm
not saying he says the exact words the
way but he laughs at how like gullible
these people are and how pathetic they
are and I mean because again he never
wanted to be around them like in the end
like he had to settle for being a cult
leader of like the lowest forms of life
barely above like the amoeba you know
instead of what he wanted to be he
wanted to be like you know this famous
you Titan of Industry real estate
developer who's cool and on reality TV
and get to hang out with all the rock
stars and the movie stars but they all
[__] hate him unless they also poop
their pants like him like Ted nent did
to get out of Vietnam otherwise can't
stand him
so well Gary's got it right it's it's
what
he it's really what he thinks so it's
what he thinks of them he does think
they're stupid and he can't believe that
they still
believe I mean he believes that they're
they're dumb as dog [__] and it's the
reason why he brags about getting rid of
roie Wade because he thinks people are
dumb but listen to this one hey I'm
proud of taking away Ro versus Wade
because if I bang you you got to keep it
and love it as much as you love me your
favorite dict
hey I'm your favorite dictator now I
mean I I I'm assuming this is real but I
you know I who can tell is it real or is
it you know truth is I I that one I
actually could have believed is real
right because he would say something
like that right he would totally say
something like that 100% there's no way
he wouldn't say something like that I
mean he says he says this he says this
um I I don't think this is AI let's
listen to this one how do you bring this
Nik Haley voters some of them voted for
you in 2020 but say they don't want you
now oh they'll all vote for me how you
bring them back into the they're going
to all vote for me again they're going
to all vote for me again everybody and
I'm not sure we need too
many so so he's he's saying two things
and it's always this way he's always
saying I mean if he doesn't contradict
himself in any 30 second statement it's
like a [__] miracle right you you've
you you've achieved one of your three
miracles for sainthood he's a complete
Mor on but but what it is funny because
if we were willing to sort of just take
the last part of that clip and show that
to that that that number we have right
that 43% of Nikki Haley voters we know
at least in Iowa I haven't seen a number
out of New Hampshire I'm sure it's even
bigger because considering so many of
them were non- Republicans who voted for
her but that 43% number in Iowa that
said that they'd vote for Biden over
Trump if if that was the choice and I
did see a lot of interviews with
individuals even some who voted for in
2020 who were just like okay they were
even like okay dude I [__]
up there's something wrong with me and
I'm getting I'm I'm seeing a shrink I'm
figuring it out but that guy that guy is
so [__] that I cannot vote I mean
seriously there were I saw a half dozen
people interviewed like that who all of
them voted for in 16 a bunch of them did
in 20 and they're just like whoa that's
enough that's enough of that [__] right
yeah and they're all Republicans so I
mean I look I don't know what's going to
happen and overall but I do know that
looking at both anecdotal and polling
evidence and the rest um grandpa Hitler
as you so fondly call him uh is is is
not is in some trouble why don't we say
that and I don't even think yet the
people that I know you love that you
personally love Lind Liz Cheney and Adam
kininger and you know others like that
have not gone on mitt Romy I'm G talk
about ROM well that dick won't even say
that he'll definitely vote for Biden so
I mean you know the one thing that that
has been sort of you know Romney his
policies basically suck every once in a
while he was he was willing to support a
child tax credit although it wasn't as
good as a Democrats I mean he did at
least one of the few Republicans who at
times tried to govern is uh he did vote
for the first impeachment like I give
credit where credit is due at the same
time the one thing that really has been
very consistent about since the first
time he actually tried to run against
Teddy Kennedy for his senate seat I
think it was in 94 got his ass handed to
him is he's pretty much been a dick like
that has been consistent that all the
people that ran against him couldn't
stand him and all the people and and so
it's like he just he has to even leave
on that way he could so easily leave
right now and say I care most about my
country and again the only statement
that follows somebody when you refer to
somebody as a threat to democracy as
somebody who's a danger to The Republic
you only statement that can follow that
and not make you look like an [__] is
you will vote for the only other viable
option right if you don't make that
statement right away if you say well you
know we'll see if Joe Mansion you know
is what he said yes even if Joe
mansion's on No Labels he's not winning
he could take enough votes to throw the
thing to Trump I don't think he would
but he I'll tell you he's he's
definitely not winning so you're gonna
vote for for some [__] loser third
candidate when you know that might help
the guy you just called the danger to to
democracy like that just leads people I
mean I mean that statement has no logic
in it what the [__] wrong with you
he's an [__] now I will I I will I
will tell you about Joe Mansion let's
let's let's back it up to the Joe
Mansion thing real quick I think it's
laughable because Joe Mansion um
obviously gave up his senate seat he's
like I'm not goingon to rerun and the
reason why is because he thought it
would launch the No Labels he did an
interview and it [__] the bed and then
he also GNA get his ass kicked I mean
right well and so it was a 30 something
point you know it's a 30 something Point
Republican state now it's one of the
most Republican states in the country
and I'll give credit where credits too
he found a way to hold on probably
because the name Mansion goes way back
his grandfather was Secretary of State
and in the state and other stuff like
that he and all the [__] coal money
his dirty coal money he found a way to
hang on by like a few points pun
intended with the Dirty Money the dirty
cold money pun intended is it yes of
course Cole I believe in that but you
know what since yeah since um since then
two things happen one if it's humanly
possible and no offense to individuals
there watching this because you are
smart but overall as a state West
Virginia's gotten even dumber and more
prot Trump that's one thing that's
happened since then and and the second
thing that's happened is Jim Justice
who's the governor who who has a name he
does not deserve and he's also a big
Cole owning guy that's where he made his
money is a billionaire and he's running
and he's the governor he has name
recognition has lots of money to spend
and is a Republican and all the polls
showed him up by somewhere between 12
and 18 points like it wasn't even close
so Mansion was GNA I mean Mansion was
going to get his ass kicked I mean is
what was going to happen I got some
breaking news um as we're talking here
um Peter Navaro I don't know if you know
this guy I think I think he's definitely
was in actually got convicted of contemp
sent to prison for maybe maybe he was he
was in the Obama administra no maybe he
was in the Biden Administration what did
what is this guy oh no that's right he
was in the Trump Administration he tried
to commit a coup and then he would six
hostages he wouldn't he wouldn't oh I
knew who said that yeah our good friend
Elise stefanic got no no no no not not
stefanic stepan epao that's what
Trump the one that thinks uh wearing
lamp shades is a lifestyle choice for
clothing look Alise Alise steppa do she
loves she loves to put on her Cheeto
dust knee pets I'm telling you clip she
Lov pump and [__] nuggets she loves it
she loves to put on her Cheeto Dusty P
that that Alise step on my dick Alise
step on my dick think why does she
always wear the drapes like what what is
it about [__] well well because she gets
her fashion advice from Sarah Huckabee
Sanders that's why that must be it yes I
mean come on can't can't you see it but
the breaking news is Peter Navaro was
sentenced to four months in prison um
now he'll actually he'll go to
detainment I'm I'm actually I actually
think he'll serve time in a federal
prison camp for this um normally if it's
like 30 60 days they'll go to like a
housing facility U because our federal
government contracts private contractors
for I want I want the super max out in
Colorado good luck them in general
population yeah Peter Navaro wouldn't
tough talking guy when he's on TV let's
see how tough he is there right right
but Peter Nar Supply him with a shank
and you know and maybe something else
and be like and we could have a version
of Survivor and just kind of watch it
see what happens now you can have two
choices he can have two choices here he
can either um try to appeal this which
the judge can actually hold him out of
his sentencing until you know the appeal
would would come do or whatever but he's
gonna serve if if this holds if this if
this sentence holds then he'll serve
every single day of the four months
that's how Federal sentences work he'll
serve every [__] day of it rather
yeah go now they will give him credit
for um detaining him they'll give him
one day's credit for detaining him um
there so he's got one day's credit so
far on his Federal president sentence
but with this four Monon sentence he
will he will report to a uh camp or he
will be given an ankle bracelet to do
his his incarceration at his house one
way or other credit for the fact that
he's have to be he's had to be locked in
his own body his entire life well I mean
that's worth at least four months that's
worth at least four months in a super
max probably probably all right so I
want to go back to some other news here
and I kind of got a question for you
cliff and the audience here first you
you go back to other news I'm going to
fix something one second yeah go ahead
go ahead um so I I want to show the
audience uh something here um this is um
a question that is worth asking um it
says what does Trump store in his neck
fold uh you guys are familiar with the
uh I got to get that off the screen
holy [__] that's disgusting um what's
with this guy's teeth too Jesus [__]
Christ you think he can afford a set a
Chompers there if you were a billionaire
I don't know um but Cliff the question
here is what does what does Trump hold
in his his neck
fold oh my oh my God so I actually Cliff
I actually think um this could be
possibility I think he holds his
collection of Putin's come in his in his
uh in his neck fold I mean where else
would he have it I mean you know what I
mean it would it kind of would reside in
his his
follows look clip excuse me excuse me I
like to taste the dick I like to taste
it but I love the money shot I love the
money shot EX for day
one I don't know if mine is going to be
quite I don't know that I can top yours
uh my feeling was just that the Mara
Lago [__] has gotten so filled up
that he he had all sorts of Secrets he
stored in there that he sto okay well
that might be that might be May secret
plans to bomb Iran and who knows what
the hell else he's got in there it could
be both it could be the secrets that he
sold for Putin's come um you know that
could maybe also there's the possibility
of some naked picks of Ivanka in there
oh oh like for got upset Putin's come is
fine but that one that was no I thought
you meant like him and him and ianka
together naked oh I meant her but I mean
you know you can create this is a Choose
Your Own Adventure right right well I
mean this is how mockery this is how
mockery works okay this is how mockery
Works speaking speaking of mocking um I
want to mock Fox News here for a minute
because this is you know how could you
not mock Fox News because you got
Grandpa Hitler here on Fox it's
hilarious that they're talking about the
economy on Fox News and they're showing
this dumb [__] we got the first
look at the fourth quarter GD number you
know that's a lot better than
expected it's The Sweet Spot it's The
Sweet Spot I mean they really love The
Sweet Spot baby you know when you got
her bent over the bed and you're really
hammering it sweet spot was in the back
after she said that taking at least four
erection
pills oh my god listen and this is where
I came up with the dark Brandon economy
this morning because I was like I I I
knew it was going to happen this morning
when I saw this I'm like oh this is such
great news and the reason why is because
they can't they can't walk away from the
idea that the economy is getting better
number one because gas prices are going
down to 250 folks if you just say that
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over you don't
have to give Biden credit baby you don't
have to give him credit just say gas
price are going down to 250 gas pric is
going down to 250 gas price is going
down to 250 over and over again the
thing is is I was like I know what these
[__] idiots are going to do and I'm
talking about the libtards out there
right the Liberals these these morons on
Twitter because they're like oh let's
wait for the president to hashtag bid
nomics I'm like oh my God they're going
to destroy this thing they're gonna set
it up this morning to where the right's
going to be like bomic that's the
dumbest thing ever and then they're
gonna have a thousand million memes that
are Gonna Knock bomic because it's a
stupid [__] word it's not actually a
word but it's a stupid ass message it
again it makes people think they're
going to go to a college course they're
going to have to take a [__] test I
have to the one thing I'll say because
slightly disagree yeah do I think it's
the best no I don't think it's as bad as
you think it is simply because we've
done this [__] like since Reagan with
everybody Reaganomics Bush anomic you
know clintonomics Obama I mean like
they've done that with every president
and yeah I think it's dumb but the only
I don't think it has as negative it
certainly I like yours much better so
let's be clear about that dark Brandon
thing is perfect because you want the
badass like
imagery of Biden kicking ass and fixing
the economy right so I mean it's like
it's like the dark Brandon economy makes
you think right away it's like it puts
in my head that picture where he's
hanging there with his arm around the
lady and the guy's got the cracker you
know alligator shirt in Florida and like
and the santis is just walking away with
his head down depressed like the the the
sort of clash of these two that's the
dark brand in
dark brand economy right and this tool
that's what I think of like brand is a
guy that comes to town puts his arm
around your girl you know sends the
loser meatball walking away like crying
like that's the that's the uh the image
that I want from this I I I'm just
saying because of it's been used so many
times it's such a boring mainstream
media thing to be like what's the
president's name let's combine that with
anomic you know I don't think as
damaging as you think it is I just think
it's not as good I actually I actually
think I actually think if we're not
doing better than we could do then we
are damaging because we just we could
just call we could just call it dark
brand in economy we can move on the
right can't attack it I mean they can
try but it'll be it if if the White
House started it started [__] pumping
out memes of Brandon with red eyes and
his aviators and it says dark Brandon
economy on it they would [__] their
[__] pants Fox News wouldn't know
what the [__] to do these righties would
be like holy goddamn who the [__] told
them to do that and they clearly get it
because they've embraced some of the
dark brand themselves they've had him in
all those cool cars with the shades on
on the motorcycle they even did the they
even did the merch they even did the
merch right so they get they get you you
know but I'm just saying in terms of
even Beyond dark Brandon they understand
the power of cool imagery him in like
the convertible right or him in like you
know on a motorcycle or they get all of
that so because they as being that they
do come on man take the next step right
well um someone on YouTube says with the
N again with the name yeah again with
the name every day every minute every
hour look listen this is how messaging
and narrative works if you just say it
once and move on it will not take hold
it will not Cascade what you have to do
is you have to have a message and a
narrative that will leak out into
American society and and culture not
that's the key that's why b nomics or
any nomics sucks because it won't leak
out into the culture you create a
culture
that's what will push a message and the
only thing we need for for Joe Biden is
for him him to have one thing that he's
touting one thing and and then he points
out the thing that they want to do
here's what I want to do dark branded
economy what they want to do is take
your [__] rights away right yeah you
contrast it I mean here's the thing like
you're exactly right you know that
you've been
successful uh with these kinds of things
when they're jokingly referring to it or
or seriously referring to on in on TV
shows when the nightly like when the
night uh comedy shows like the jimmies
and all of them are are making reference
to it in other words that's when you
know you've gotten Beyond just the
political bubble and you've reached a
point where actual regular people are
seeing it and taking it in and we'll
start talking about it and that's the
most important thing that's the most
important the way you do that as you
just said is not only do you have to
repeat it numerous times for it to be
something that that people will remember
but you have to repeat it numerous times
in front of the sort of elite
Gatekeepers the New York Times types and
whatever so that they'll write about it
because if you don't make this is what I
this is the stuff I've yelled about for
so many years with Democrats and again
we've gotten so much better and we have
a number of people that are just I mean
you know uh what's her name Crockett is
just the most amazing Communicator swell
is a great communicator like I there's a
bunch of them that we've got now that
know how to do this stuff Hakeem Jeff is
one of the best messagers bar
you know we we've been great legislators
for a while now Nancy Pelosi is an
incredible legislator horrible messenger
hor I'll give her all the credit in the
world for that and say she's
groundbreaking she's amazing she's on
the Mount Rushmore most effective
Speaker of the House in modern history
most effective ever but I would argue is
just from a communication standpoint
there should have been somebody out
there sharing the message that was that
was what they were better at and that we
should have been more aggressive and
we've been getting slowly more
aggressive we were more aggressive and
2020 you know I wrote some ads for Biden
that was part of what I did that year
and they allowed some things I was
surprised they allowed um and so we've
been moving there but it's been a slow
process but I do really feel like
because we've got some more aggressive
people who are willing to say some of
this stuff that we're out there with
some of this now and and that's what you
have to do you grab the dark Brandon
thing because once you do that
Republicans I mean whether it's alore
inventing the internet or John krey
being a flip-flopper all this [__]
that they invented about Democrats
that's what they did they repeated it
and this is pre- Twitter and pre they
repeated it again and again and again in
front of the media to the media started
writing about it once the wrote about it
it took off that was it well and and
they had no shame doing it we should
have no shame and you know I said I've
said the last few weeks um since we've
kicked off this operation go commando uh
where we're trying to court other
coalitions to you know ban together in
this mission of mockery um and I think
someone had tweeted out or put in the
comments Rock the mock um so mockery is
the is the best tool and Republicans in
the rightwing have always always known
this and the dark Brandon is a great
Mock and and because it will mock them
um and and it will draw in people go
whoa dark Brandon economy what the hell
does that mean and then once they find
out they like yeah gas prices are 250
that's cool um then that's the dark as
you said you do things in threes a lot
of time they're alliterative if they can
be like you know if I refer to Trump I'd
be like diapers dementia and
dictatorship that's my my description of
a trump presidency and like it gets you
to laugh as you did it gets you to think
you know about the things that are most
scary about him and he kind of gets you
there so I've been doing a little bit of
that kind of stuff too yeah well let's
let's expand on that I I like that I
like that
uh and dictatorship that's what you get
with Trump a trump presidency diapers
dementia and dictatorship yeah that's
that's pretty that that says it all that
says it all right there um so I want to
I want to move on to speaking of
messaging if you got I don't do you have
a heart out do you have a heart out at
all uh I do not okay well I do I mean
however I I definitely I'm I'm actually
doing a another podcast it's I don't
usually have that much at two but uh so
I have to get I'd have to probably be so
let's let's let's go over this subject
really quick um and I mean unless you
want to kick me off I got at least
another well well let's let's do 10
minutes let's do 10 or 15 minutes on
your favorite guy Mitt Romney here I
want to talk about this [__] okay um
because he said something about the
Border this morning we could go over a
thousand different things of Mitt Romney
and blah blah blah and um but this is
another before you can say it my my now
17-year-old who at the time when Mitt
Romney was running so were we 24 now was
12 he was he was five um God that's hard
to even believe uh he uh he heard me
Romney and I remember him being like is
that Buzz Lightyear because that's how
boring he was Romney sounded like such a
I tweeted that out and no did I tweet at
the time because yeah Twitter was around
but I remember putting it up on Facebook
and everybody just [__] loved it
because it was so accurate right my kid
wasn't trying to make fun of him he just
was like is that Lightyear right the
darn the kids say the darnest things and
so does Mitt Romney he says the darnest
that Mitt Romney says the darnest things
Mitt Romney is an [__] now I will
give him credit as Cliff did
voting for impeachment I think Mitt
Romney voted for impeachment not because
he truly wanted to impeach Donald Trump
I believe the reason why is because Mitt
Romney knew it be written in the history
books and Mitt Romney is not an idiot
right Mitt Romney understands Legacy
probably better than any Republican
since John McCain like he really truly
understands Legacy that's why John
McCain did the thumbs down is because he
understood Legacy he really truly
understood the immortal um uh this this
immortal Immortal piece of what you can
be as a politician especially United
States Senator when making um pivotal
he's been govern senator of a different
state he's not going to be president
he's not going to be in any kind of a
trump cabinet and chances are you know
when he keeps walking around being an
idiot he wouldn't be any kind of a Biden
cabinet either so this is as as close as
he's goingon to get so yeah you do that
vote what whether he believed it or not
I appreciate his doing it right you're
right it does it does put you in a
history books right he he is the only
he's the only one that voted uh uh to
Impe to remove Donald Trump I don't
think any Republicans in the house voted
for so think he's the only one who voted
either so this this guy's the only one
to do that but listen to what he says
about the border and then I'm going to
talk to you about messaging and see what
you think see if I'm on to something
here listen I think I think the border
is a very important issue for Donald
Trump uh and the fact that he would
communicate to uh Republican Senators
and Congress people that he doesn't want
us to solve the Border problem because
he wants to blame uh Biden for it is uh
is really appalling but okay so and the
story is is that Republicans really hate
that we don't have border security but
they're not willing to do anything about
it that's kind of the story but here's
the thing is that here's my view on it
and I've been um saying this speaking of
messaging and narrative Republicans and
Democrats especially Democrats need to
stop saying the border is a problem and
people coming over into our country is a
problem they need to stop saying that it
is not a problem for people who want to
come to America and be American and come
be part of our economy the dark Brandon
economy and be a part of our society and
contribute to our communities and be
integral part of our communities that's
not a problem that's actually the
American way that's the American dream
it's American Experience if you want to
know the honest truth it's the reason
why America exists in the first place so
people crossing over an imaginary line
is not the problem it is how we treat
them when we get when they get here and
how we treat them if we want them to
leave or if we need to get them to leave
for whatever reason that is the problem
and really honestly that's just the
symptom of the problem if you want to
know the truth the real problem is
Washington DC it's always been
Washington DC this is a federal border
this isn't a state border this isn't the
County Line This is a federal border it
is Washington DC that that is the only
Congress and the Senate is the only
bodies in Washington that can legislate
anything and set policy at the border
that that is that's it it's washingt we
we weren't sure of that for a second
because four members of the Supreme
Court actually basically voted in favor
of the Civil War when they voted and
said the supremacy clause doesn't matter
I mean it again we miss out on stories
like that because we're so busy with
Trump and everything but if you think
about it how [__] incredible it is
that of nine Supreme Court Justices four
of these Jack offs who clearly care
nothing or understand nothing about us
history were willing to vote to allow a
state to Def to defy the federal
government on an issue that is clearly a
federal issue that's why they're there
though that's why those Supreme Court
Justice and that's why they're paid to
be there that's why they are of course
that's why all of that but but our
reaction to that should be expand the
[__] out of the court because these
people aren't just you know slightly off
they represent they literally oppose our
constitution on a daily basis right well
and and again back to what they say is
the problem which is not the problem and
I need I need people to understand that
this is an important part and integral
part of why we keep having this stupid
[__] fight and by we I mean people
who are pro- democracy who who want
migrants to come here and want them to
have have to become American and have
their children become American their
grandchildren become American just like
you you and I are like we I my family
you know they snuck being attacked my
family was pretty much kicked out of
everywhere you know so right so but they
came here to become American and for you
to become American I mean that's the
idea that's the whole the dream The
Experience whatever the hell anyone
wants to call it um until we stop doing
that right and I mean us as in everyone
stop treating the fact that people
crossing an imaginary line as the
problem that is not the [__] problem
that is not the problem that is not the
problem that is not the problem and when
Washington Democrats included in this
come to that conclusion then they start
messaging in a way that hey it's not the
people coming across the boorder that's
the problem it's these [__] idiots
that won't that won't get their act
together in the federal government to
figure out what the hell we're going to
do when they want when they get here
because we need labor we need people in
our communities we need this we need we
need Equity it's important that you say
this that they're not the problem
they're actually with the problem is is
as I think what you're saying here is we
have a lack of rules and regulations we
have a lack of of a plan or program for
how we treat folks who come here and we
had on numerous occasions now for the
last 15 20 years bills in place that
were bipartisan and would have solved a
lot of that a classic example was the
the one that the Senate voted on that
got 68 votes including people like John
Corin and Lindsey Graham and all these
guys and I'm trying to remember that was
about a decade ago and that the
Republican house blocked okay so we
don't have anything in place to to solve
a a a you know I agree with you it's not
a I'm trying to think of how to refer to
it it's not a problem it's a problem
because they're people are in danger
because we've ignored all of this
because we we try the Democrats and a
few Republicans try to pass stuff and
everybody and the these other
Republicans block it and they do that
not just because Trump right now they've
been doing it for years because they've
known that if you look at how right-wing
parties have been able to win in Europe
and places like that it's on this issue
it's by demonizing immigrants and so to
them that's a road map to being able to
win here is to embrace the worst most
horrible aspects of it
way oh I didn't hear that what was that
catapulting illegals over the wall who
said that Laura Laura wisk she was the
US Senate um of of Delaware she was the
US and 2020 also catapult her over a
wall and that would be fun I mean you
want me to show you the full clip I'll
show you the full CLI I love showing
second I just just go go ahead finish up
and I'll I'll find this which is which
is there that this is a policy issue and
much like the infrastructure Bill we
need a new infrastructure we solved it
here whether it comes to to putting
enough money into facilities for people
into a system that that takes people and
makes them become first you know
Americans in terms of green card holders
eventually citizens where there where
their taxes they pay you know where
corporations that are obviously as you
said and need the labor or hiring them
or paying taxes or you know whatever it
is I mean there's there's numerous ways
to take what is a policy issue and solve
it and the Democrats have now proposed
at least on the last 20 years three or
four different bills that would bring a
bunch of of of uh different ideas
together to do that so it would be a
better situation and and Republican
response is to claim they're Christian
to apparently never have read the
parable of the Good Samaritan and think
that the parable of the Good Samaritan
was not that you come upon the Samaritan
Came Upon a traveler on the highway and
fed and clothed and helped him out but
they show up and kick him in the ribs
and maybe put an AR-15 to his head and
Surround him with barbed wire and and
let him drown like I mean we should
let's just sort of call them out I'm so
tired of their fake Christian [__]
white Christian nationalists here we go
you want to see their fake Christian
[__] out in full force because this
is this is the other thing that I've
been talking about a lot lately is that
that this is this is the actual disease
that our country has um Trump is just a
symptom of the disease he's just a
symptom like if you if you have an STD
and you're growing warts on your balls
right and you cut the wart off right and
you're gonna have more warts grow back
because you're not treating the solve
the
actual when he blocked the Supreme Court
Justice Donald Trump wasn't around you
know when new gingr did so many of the
broke so many of the laws and and had to
end up resigning from the house and was
lying and was going after Bill Clinton
on a trumped up know pun intended
impeachment while he's busy cheating on
I don't even remember his second wife
with his third wife that that [__]
you know that defective Barbie doll wife
of his or you know whatever that I mean
they've just they've allowed the worst
people in the world to gain control of
their party and as you're saying right
now play people's worst instincts and
lie and and share conspir iraes and once
people fell for these lies and these
conspiracies the rest of this garbage a
Donald Trump type figure was inevitable
you listen listen to laori she was the
US Senate candidate us us Republican US
Senate candidate in Delaware in 2020
listen to what she has to say about
about the migrants president Trump I
want you to throw Hillary Clinton and
GMO Obama and GMO just all of them just
like clean out the federal government
and send them to Guantanamo Bay and like
and I hope he goes full dictator
scorched catapulting illegals over the
wall like that would be awesome there
you go there you go that's that's the
message that's the message that's the
message I would pull something out of
Monty Python and I swear I would
catapult her over a wall but maybe
filled with flaming [__] and and I'd be
just fine with that would be awesome and
here's that' be awesome I mean but the
thing is is that and this is the point
you have made that it should be so
plainly clear uh that you know know a
lot of people have to try to get it
wrong when they try to make it that oh
it's just Trump you know and I think Liz
Cheney and some of them tried that
initially and then it was like oh well
look at everybody supporting Trump maybe
they're a problem too they're willing to
I mean that clip you just played can you
not see Marjorie Taylor green saying
that oh absolutely well you know
speaking or in your state Josh Holly
saying something like that speaking of
that I well they say it in private they
may that Trump is just a symptom well
and here's the thing is that I don't
understand that clip I just showed you
have you never seen that clip um that
clip I just showed you um I have no idea
why the mainstream media and cable news
isn't showing these clips like this over
and over and over and over and over and
over and over and over again and the
reason why is is because the people
crossing the imaginary line is not the
problem it is how we treat those people
when they get here and why Christian
nationalists want to [__] catapult
them over the
wall how it's it's the lack again of a
system that to that we do not have a
Humane a smart system set up to take
care of people and to you know integrate
them into American society and all this
stuff and again that is because a bunch
of Republicans blocked the bill with
funding and laws and other things that
would do that because they did not want
it to happen it's so it's that's the
issue again like anything else there's a
solution to our gun problem Republicans
just won't do it okay fine I'm racist
there's a solution our problem I didn't
hear it again say about us okay fine I'm
racist call me that it's fine I don't
care what these people say about
us I'm gonna now who's that um well this
is Moody she's a commentator as well um
she loves to go on St Peters show I
don't know if you know who St Peters is
um don't and I feel kind of Lucky for
that but you listen I I'm telling you
you need to we need to figure out who
these people are because these people
are the the people who Cascade the
message out into I know they reached the
Grassroots well and and and it's the
Mitt Romney and um the Liz chenies and
the Paul Ryan who end up taking a very
watered down piece of this message over
the decades But Here recently they don't
take a water down piece of this message
it's people like micro Johnson the
wiener of the house it's people like
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
and Matt gats it's all these people who
take they don't take a water down piece
of this message they run with it listen
to this I actually think Republicans
should embrace this you know I'm so sick
of Republicans Trying To Shimmy away and
shy away from the whole narrative that
we're white Christian nationalists no
that's what the Republican Party should
be we should try to go back to our
traditional Roots America is a white
Christian Nation and it's okay that we
want to maintain that Nation we want to
maintain what the country was founded on
let's Embrace this let's stop letting
the left attack us embrace the attacks
they always call us racist okay fine I'm
racist call me that it's fine I don't
care what these people say about us so
there you go there you go she's racist
yeah she don't care call her racist I
mean I'm G call like I can call her
racist all day long also among other
things I can think of I can call her
stupid annoying uh and and frankly hope
that maybe I get a chance to catapult
her over her wall too well again and
then now I I I I'm sure you haven't seen
that clip either and the reason why is
because no one plays these clips of the
actual disease no one shows where this
stuff is coming from and why they think
this way uh and I know you probably
gotta go you're getting phone call that
was a okay so so let's let's do this go
ahead H give your best pitch to the
audience right now um for Cliff sheor
and then and then we'll let you go my
best holy [__] people okay I have a
channel and uh it's it's a YouTube
channel and I'm not as as cool as Tony
but I'm like 88% is cool and it we we
have Clips every day ripping the [__]
out of for the most part Republicans
here and there a Dean Phillips type but
uh it's the the Channel's been growing
quickly it's fun you'll like it there's
lots of jokes uh it's Cliff no I'm
stupid that's my [__] Twitter it's
sector uh because I'm really smart and
made the two things different because
that's good branding uh and so it's at C
Shor come over and sign up at YouTube
and think you will enjoy it just search
Cliff Sher the name's at the bottom here
it's s c h c t er sh as as Tony was
talking about us all coming over here on
the boat over the second H got chucked
overboard into the ocean oh so it's just
c r you you got the the whole thing
right there on your screen come by
Please Subscribe we're growing and uh
you know we're having a [__] good
time like Tony is here so every single
day every single weekday clip thanks for
joining us as uh always every single
week we'll see we'll see you next week
my friend everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after this see you
later
Cliff we'll be right back Mark 60
seconds this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza magic eat pepperoni hug spot Pizza
your tummy say thank you your mouth say
m pepperoni hugs spot it's like family
but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv SL the Tony Michaels we're
back to the king of Brilliance this is
the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast welcome back to the show oh boy
do you want to see a a video of Peter
Navaro crying because he had a 4 year or
four months excuse me it should be four
year [__] him [__] Peter Naro [__] him
[__] him Peter Naro received a
four-month prison sentence for his
criminal contempt in Congress let's
listen to him crying whining about it so
what we gonna do is uh say a few words
and I'm gonna have uh several These Fine
attorneys behind me uh say a few
words wait wait wait wait wait wait I
hear the whistle in the
background
so these [__] fall around Peter
Navaro every time he does a press
conference like this and the reason why
is because Peter nabarro cannot afford
to to actually set up a press conference
room somewhere like rent a room and
actually have a a real [__] press
conference
right so he's got to do it outside the
courthouse where the media will set up
right outside the courthouse where it's
free because it's a sidewalk well
because it's a sidewalk it's a public
place anyone can [__] show up and
anyone can be you can't kick people off
the sidewalk it's the [__] sidewalk
it's
public a stupid [__] man why
does he keep doing these like this I
have no idea and you see the guy with
the sign here the lock him up
sign it's Peter deor is
[__] all right keep going
with the Whistle the top line here is
that hey knock it off hey knock it off
all right would you
please they don't have to stop blowing
into the whistle they're in public they
can blow the whistle it's during the day
there's probably no disturbance laws to
that point of the of what how loud a
whistle is
um so they can sit there and blow the
[__] whistle if they want so you
knock it off I mean really the person
who should knock it off is Peter Naro
you know stop knock it off stop
committing Crime Stop committing crime
that would be great if you just would
stop committing crime and you would not
try to overturn the government and then
and then when we try to get the evidence
that you committed crime and help
Grandpa Hitler try to overturn the
government and commit a coup we would
like for you to uh I don't know comply
with the law that'd be nice so knock it
off and stop being a [__] criminal
that would be good that'd be a nice
thing for you to do all right keep going
there
Peter yeah the top line here is that uh
Mr Woodward has already filed the
appeal uh in
this so
whistles
cowbells and
[Music]
signs oh my God this is [__] great
you have any Commandos
here this is great um this is the
perfect kind of mockery right like you
she ain't even saying words and he he
can't concentrate because the [__]
whistle is going you know what I mean so
he can't keep his [__] mind straight
because he's so pissed off that this
[__] lady won't stop Bing into the
goddamn
whistle cuz whistles kill fascist it's
so great not only does this mic
microphone kill fascist a [__] simple
whistle a simple [__] whistle will
kill a fascist it's great keep going
case this is a case of First
Impressions that I have said from day
one and here she is in the
background Peter Navaro is a liar with
the cowbell and the sign oh my god
listen if you if you ever if you ever
wanted show your kids or your grandkids
friends family I don't know people who
aren't aren't citizens of this country
if you want to show them if you want to
show them what democracy looks like if
you want to show them what democracy
looks like this is a perfect [__]
image right here you got Peter Naro this
[__] entitled white old wrinkly ball
sack who fucking's committing crime and
the crime that he committed is just not
[__] admitting the truth that's it
that's the that's the literal crime that
he has done is he was held in contempt
of congress criminal contempt of
congress because he wouldn't hand over
the evidence of a crime that he was
helping Grandpa poopy pants Grandpa
Hitler overturn our government in a
Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup and there behind him is a woman
which the party and the man who he
supported in that coup took away her
[__] rights took away her [__]
rights to Health Care ban Banning her
privacy in her goddamn doctor's office
and there she's standing with a goddamn
a a cowbell a piece of poster board with
some markings on
it and it's pissing him the [__]
off you want to see a picture of
democracy this is the perfect [__]
example of democracy right here this is
it democracy with mockery you goddamn
right part of operation go commando you
know what I think I'm going to f I'm I I
I I think I've got this lady's Twitter
handle I think what I'll do is I am
going to invite her to be part of
operation go commando that's right I'm
GNA reach out to her and you all should
too you should reach out to her and
let's recruit her to operation go
commando
because she's [__] she's [__]
fantastic [__] fantastic and she is
she is a Commando for democracy for
sure um because again this is the
perfect example if you want a picture of
what democracy can and should be and and
can do it is this right here that this
man listen listen a four-month prison
sentence and no one wants to go to
prison no one no one wants to go to a
federal prison okay I've been there no
one wants to go there right they just
you just don't but four months is no
[__] it's no big deal
right I I was locked up I was locked up
for almost a year that was no big deal I
thought it was at the time looking back
on it I was mistaken it's not it's not
really that big of a deal it really
isn't honestly it humbles you it it
teaches you who you are if you want to
know the honest
truth if you do but four [__] months
man quit your [__] bitching quit your
crying take your [__] hit on the chin
quit being a little goddamn [__] quit
trying to [__] Serve Yourself by
having some kind of press conference
outside the [__] courtroom where you
can [__] Yap and blah blah yakety
smacking into the microphone about how
you're a goddamn victim just take it on
the chin and go do your [__] time
buddy just do it all
right just do it is destined for the
Supreme Court it is a case that really
asks the important
question of whether a senior White House
Aid and Alter Ego or the
president can be compelled to
testify
by and this is where we're at
unfortunately do you have any Commandos
here the opposition behind us won't let
this be heard but we're going to do our
best
the opposition well be the opposition
meaning people who want him to be
sentenced to prison for the crime that
he committed on America by the way
America these are crimes that they
committed against
America okay not he didn't he didn't
[__] steal a pack of gum all right he
didn't [__] sell a dime bag okay
this guy committed crimes against
[__] America they were trying to
overturn our
Constitution and he was hiding evidence
he wouldn't [__] give the evidence he
wouldn't
give deposition to the truth so [__]
this guy he deserves a hell of a lot
more a hell of a lot more than [__]
four months as far as I'm concerned and
really honestly and these people with
the cowbells and the
whistles are hell of a lot they got more
they got more of being American and them
in their [__] Pinky nail than Peter
Navaro has in 20, thousands of his of
his
body he has no clue what America's about
he's been entitled his whole goddamn
life there's nothing that has reigned on
him but [__]
privilege and it it's he reeks he reeks
a white male fragility because honestly
Peter honestly if you wanted to be able
to give your speech maybe what and you
knew that these [__] people would be
because you knew these people are going
to be standing there with the cow bells
and the whistles you dumb [__]
you knew it then what you would have
done is you would have been given the
speech in the mirror with two or three
people whistling in your ear so that you
could give the speech that you wanted to
give without the distraction of the
[__] whistles and if you can't stand
there and concentrate on what you want
to say
when there's a couple people whistling
and and ringing cow bells as you're
trying to give your statement then your
statement's probably a bunch of [__]
lies in the first
place [__]
[__] good four [__]
months what a [__] joke Peter Navaro
and that prison
sentence what a [__]
joke kiss my [__] ass all right we
got we got one more um clip of this
because it's so good yeah yeah I'm going
to keep playing this I
promise here here's another clip of it
um yeah look I'd be happy to talk to
some of the uh print media inside so
we're not harassed by uh these folks
here maybe you should have been inside
in the first place you dumb
[__] you dumb son of a [__] oh my God
what an idiot listen dude just go rent a
hotel conference room right because if
Peter Navaro would rent a conference
room these people wouldn't be allowed in
because now it's his rented space it's
not public anymore and he could have
rented a conference room but he didn't
maybe he wants this imagery I don't know
why you would you look weak and feeble
again the important issue here is the
central constitutional issue about the
separation of powers and the
Integrity of presidential decision
making oh he's so concerned about the
constit if you can hear it over the
cowbells and the
whistles he's so concerned about the
Constitution so it's a constitutional
issue he's so concerned about the
Constitution that he was willing to [__]
on it rip it up and let Grandpa poopy
pants be a dictator get the [__] out of
here with your constitutional talk you
can kiss my [__] ass you piece of
treason is trash [__] you Peter Navaro
with your constitutional
[__] I have been caught in a battle
between two competing branches of
government oh my god um this is this is
uh we're about halfway to resolving this
case so I appreciate this um I'm sorry
for
the video cameras that you can't get
clean sound because
but but this is
what did you hear that wait for wait go
back go back go back go back listen what
he says this is great and then listen to
what the lawyer right here says when he
says the he listen to what he says and
then and then listen to what the [__]
cowbell lady says listen that you can't
get clean sound because
of the
commies the commies yes
the commies antifa we we broadcast every
single weekday from the the antifa
headquarters in Kami Falls Missouri
that's where the antifa headquarters is
located right here in commi Falls
Missouri that's where we broadcast every
single week day so he's on to something
[__] you [__] commies with your
whistles in your cowboy
bells are you a cowbell
commi the cowbell commi
Commandos oh my God these [__] [__]
boxes don't even know what they're
walking into but listen to what she says
after listen to what she says after see
if you can hear it because
of but but this is
what for Congress is
hilarious the
commies this is what has happened to
this country and it's it's unfortunate
that they won't respect my First
Amendment right here Harry done for
congress Peter Navaro is now a January 6
hostage oh [__] um look i' be happy to
talk to some of the uh the print media
oh my God okay wait wait there's another
one we've got five minutes oh I'm not
stopping I'm not stopping
this make a suggestion yeah if these
commies behind us are going to keep on
banging around so you can't have a
straight thought or be able to answer a
question
with if these
commies this is his attorney all right
that guy that keeps calling the woman
who
is who is operating under her
constitutional right to stand on the
sidewalk and blow a whistle and and ring
a cowbell and hold the sign that's
that's her constitutional right she can
stand on the sidewalk and do that [__]
she's in public there's a right to
protest and by God that sometimes that's
the best way to protest is hold a sign
and blow a [__] whistle right
obviously when he says if these commies
he's that's his
attorney you want to know why Peter
dvaro just got [__] four months in
federal prison is because his attorney
believes that people blowing whistles
and holding signs on sidewalks are
communist
he believes I mean he's saying out loud
he's saying out loud that democracy that
protesting that's commi type that's
commi type
talk well that makes me a communist I
guess because I'm all for it you [__]
bonehead let's go back to this is this
is some of the best tape I've seen in a
long
time
[Music]
January the the craziest part about this
is these two [__] old wrinkly ball
sacks back
here A bunch of trump supporters paid
these guy through this guy to stand
there to listen to this
[__] Laura you got it right you got it
right Laura on Facebook says commies for
democracy commi Commandos the cowbell
commi
Commandos
God more cowbell
[Music]
please I have no comment
the this issue is simply about the
Constitutional separation of powers
executive
privilege and the
Integrity of presidential decision
making this is a principle that goes
back to the days of George Washington so
anyway write your stories well I
appreciate it uh I've got a big fight
ahead of me I've got great great folks
behind me defend peter.com please defend
peter.com help me raise the money in
order to fight this
battle help me raise the money to to pay
these
[__] so that way they can call
people standing on the sidewalk
operating underneath their
constitutional rights and Duty
call them
commies oh I love this [__] I [__]
love this [__] what what a great
showing what a great showing oh oh oh I
I found I do follow her oh my God this
is
great um I can't message her on Twitter
here's here's her here's her um the guy
the little lady with the sign Harry dun
for congress as she's yelling and Trump
lost and you can and you know it there's
another sign she's been doing this and
trolling this [__] every time he
has a he has a sidewalk press conference
but here's her um here's her Twitter
handle and she's got a link tree here
hey let's go to that let's see if we can
uh we need to recruit this person to our
um we need to recruit this
person
to has she got an email a contact twitch
she's got a YouTube she's got a Twitter
no
you know what I might send her a vinmo
you know what I mean if you go to her
link tree here if you go to a link tree
she's got a vinmo just tag me in her
vinmo I don't know give her a dollar or
two I might give her a dollar or two
just to tag her say hey come on the show
come on the show and join the cowbell
Kami
Commandos the cowbell Kami Commandos oh
yeah here's the here's the in image of
the cowboy commi Commandos instead of
the cowbell but it's close the
cowbell coming
Commandos in operation go
commando always punch a Nazi all right
all right that's it that's it that's all
the time we got I've wasted the last 10
minutes with the Peter Navaro getting
had on a sidewalk by a by a cowbell Kami
Commando and a whistle they're scared of
these fascists are terrified terrified
of cow bells and whistles
poor goddamn things don't forget I'm
getting my tattoo tomorrow are you
[__] kidding me did we talk about
this today yet we haven't talked about
this today yet holy [__] I'm getting my
tattoo tomorrow speaking of killing
fascists this microphone kills fascist
this one right here and I'm getting a
tattoo that says it tomorrow that's
right tomorrow afternoon and you still
have time you still have time to get in
on the live stream there's been almost
30 people want to be in on the live
stream and they're part of Team tattoo
that's team tattoo if you want to be
part of Team tattoo and you want to see
the live stream first you want to be the
first group of people to see the live
stream go join team tattoo all you got
to do is just give any amount a dollar$
two dollars I think if I I think we're
almost less than
$100 to our goal go check it out go to
go to the Tony michaels.com click team
tattoo fund I'm getting the tattoo that
is inspired by this merch tomorrow
that's right tomorrow afternoon and
we'll be doing the live streams tomorrow
afternoon here's how it's going to work
if you have given to teen tattoo fund
and you're part of teen tattoo you're in
like Flynn meaning I've got your email
and that's where you're going to receive
the notifications of the live stream so
be watching your email tomorrow
afternoon watch your emails tomorrow
afternoon and you will see um those
emails come in with those links to those
live streams so you'll have the links to
go to um and tomorrow afternoon and I'm
I'm going to set up like four or five so
there going be like four or five streams
um for you guys so there'll be different
times and we'll be talking about
different stuff during those line
streams I'm hoping one of them is like
during the middle or end of the tattoo
and I'm in immense pain so that you guys
can see me wincing in pain from the
tatto that's what I want I I I think
that would make good content I'm not
gonna lie so go to Theon mich.com check
out team tattoo fun give any amount be
part of Team tattoo and get those live
streams tomorrow speaking of tomorrow we
got bonehead of the week so we'll have
the guy with the last name Sanchez
joining us tomorrow same time same place
Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
in political news no rules No Boundaries
I think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow Tony
on social media @ the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
I got a
fever and the only prescription is more
[Music]
cowbell so I'm gonna do is uh say a few
words and I'm gonna have U several These
Fine attorneys behind me uh say a few
words but the top line here is
that
Mr yeah the top line here is that uh Mr
Woodward has already filed the
appeal uh in this case this is a case of
First
Impressions that I have said from day
one is destined for the Supreme Court it
is a case that really asked the
important
question of whether a senior White House
Aid and Alter Ego of the
president can be compelled to
testify by Congress and this is where
we're at
unfortunately um the opposition behind
us won't let this be heard but we're
going to do our best here uh the one
thing
I